take a look at steven's numbers brought
to you by the pennsylvania lottery
excellent era of 193 of course just 18
innings but
still that's pretty darn good
not giving up a lot of hits opponents
just hitting 229. and mostly his
opponents have been cardinals
and this should be the first out and
wouldn't you know it it's going to be
the right fielder
michael chavis baseball's a funny game
they say michael chavis getting his
first start as a pirate in right field
high pop
could be a one two three inning for
stephen brault
kept looking over reynolds like are you
gonna make this catch
adam wainwright is on the mound he's won
seven straight against the pirates
no cardinal has ever won eight straight
starts against pittsburgh
so i guess the question is how is he
doing it
in the cat and mouse game ricky and keel
of major league baseball as you get a
look at the hyundai pitch arsenal where
you're always making adjustments but yet
he seems to find a way
the o2 pitch
little bouncer back to adam wainwright
he'll step and throw goldie there
there's the first out
keep brian hayes at the plate and a
ground ball oh what a play here arenado
spinning and robbing key brian hayes
terrific play down at third nolan
oronato man is he good over there so
here's molina eight game hitting streak
on the line tonight nine for his last
31.
driven into the gap in right center
cut off by reynolds
and yachty the wide turn around first
base he'll stop there
and the first hit in our ball game
tonight and that hit passes gary
carter's seventh
all-time among primary catchers and hits
in baseball history for catchers the
one-two pitch
sosa drives it
out to left center that ball all the way
to the wall
molina will score
carlson being waved in he will score
so set a third with a triple that drives
in two two nothing st louis
knocked it down and had a play between
third and first but decides to go to
first for the second out here is michael
chavis
there's a ground ball to nolan arnotto
five up five down cardinals defense may
be busy tonight with the way things are
going
inside corner comes back to get him in
his first strikeout of the night
six up six down tommy edmond who flied
to right to start our ball game
that's in the gap again
near that 410 sign camel cuts it off
edmond to second base
and it's a lead off double
the 3-2
goldie hits it the other way base hit
edmond will score
and it's three to nothing cardinals rbi
number 75 for paul goldschmidt
o'neal rips it for a base hit out to
left
runners at first and second and here
comes nolan aronado
base head into right field
off the bat of nolan arenado
they're gonna hold up paul goldschmidt
and the base is loaded for yadier molina
a little number off the end of the bat
bro it will throw hall back goodness
he's an athlete and a throw to first and
almost
got two perez just uh too late to throw
to first base wow it almost looks as
though he threw his left arm up almost
to distract brawl
got him chase
high target he put it right there the
2-1 pitch
and sosa hits it out to right center
it's down they're off to the races
sosa another extra base hit two runs
have scored here comes another and it's
another triple for edmundo sosa have a
game two for two
two triples and he has driven in five of
the six tonight
bueno hits it up the middle base head
sosa will score
seven nothing
turns out to be a rough outing for
stephen brault three innings seven runs
and gives way to kyle keller
toward right and michael chavis
will make the catch
good job his first start in the big
leagues in right field adam wainwright
back to work bottom of the fourth inning
he's been perfect so far
grounded back to wayne wright to start
things offensively for the pirates and
that strikeout number two ten up ten
down and this is start number 352 that
he was perfect first time through the
order and needed under 30 pitches to do
it so uh moran tap back to the mound
will be the first one
to try it
here's the set by wainwright the o1 is
lined into center there's a base hit
colin moran with a lead off single to
center there goes a no-hitter joey got a
curveball that stayed up in the strike
zone
with a high fly ball into center going
back bader he's got it
near the wall and fires back into the
infield
a strong throw on the fly to goldie
it's fun to watch him play defense there
you see a great jump moving to his left
over his shoulder you see the short
steps there he's no he's getting close
to the wall timing it so he can do just
that turn around and fire it first
anthony bonda and his numbers brought to
you by shili's
and it takes another
on another elevated fastball he's down
on strikes for the first out
the pitch slowly hit ground ball toward
third key brian hayes throws on the run
tommy is safe 2-2 pitch
ripped fair down into the left field
corner tommy edmond off to the races
heading to third
being waved in here comes tommy
he'll score and goldie is driven in a
pair tonight
he's up to 76 and it's eight nothing
cardinals
this one hit well to left camel back on
the run and he'll make the catch
two-handed against the wall to end the
inning what a great play by ben campbell
and to lead it off for the pirates
michael perez
swing and a miss there's that curveball
and the strikeout for wainwright that's
number four tonight doesn't walk the man
and he's allowed just one hit
and the left center field a two strike
hit into left center for gamel
oh look at that it's off the back
and campbell goes to second
huh
when's the last time you saw that or
whatever
whatever i've ever seen that before
there you go that's what i was looking
for but i know it was one of those
before this year never seen that before
they throw the ball in
and hit the back and give up an extra
base
and a fly ball into center bader diving
comes up with it what a catch
harrison bader takes the hit
and rbi away
keeps the pirates off the board luis
oviedo is now pitching
and the bases are loaded he walks adam
wainwright
tommy grounds it right side race to the
bag and safe at first and a run will
score to make it nine nothing so tommy
edmond has brought in six in this series
and his hustle down the line creates a
nine-nothing lead for the cardinals
three-two pitch here it comes
and he walked him
four walks in the inning goldschmidt
picks up the rbi there's two strikes
here it is swinging a miss struck him
out
and that ends the inning
cardinals get two it's been filling the
strike zone up the curveball's been
fantastic popped up
so wainwright tonight is going to give
the cardinals
seven
shutout innings
and now dylan carlson jumps on one
alford back oh off the glove and over
the wall for a home run he had it for a
moment i think yeah in fact carlson was
headed back to his dugout
he thought it was caught he was headed
back to the dugout and they told him no
that's a home run
his 13th
it's 12 nothing
over three twice grounded out to third
ground ball could be two the turn double
play cardinals have a shutout in
pittsburgh wainwright was fantastic
seven shutout innings the cardinals
score seven in the first three innings
and then keep adding runs the sixth the
seventh and eighth added runs to it
great game for the birds